so week one well start off with I was in
Germany which was it
actually it was mildly terrifying I've
done a lot of public speaking before but
I can't honestly remember the last time
I was that nervous about giving a talk
probably because I was talking about
maths which I only just about have a
handle on to a group of experts or at
least I thought it was going to be a
group of experts as it turns out the
conference which was data analysis and
modeling in Earth Sciences had a whole
range of people giving talks and a whole
range of professionals who were Tanja so
yeah there are mathematicians and
physicists but there were also
geographers meteorologists where else
was the people who were giving talks on
sustainable development people who do
just just computer modeling so it was a
whole range of people which meant that
actually weren't that many people who
sort of technically had a great
understanding what I was talking about
which was great conference was really
nice actually was in this hotel which is
in Potsdam and because it was Germany we
had beer and pretzels which was very
nice and me my supervisor who really
nice dinner the night before which is
really nice actually being able to just
chat quite candidly about PhD
applications and stuff like that I got
back at about one o'clock in the morning
on Tuesday and then Tuesday itself I
managed to on the first night of term I
was actually back in Oxford I triple
booked myself so I had to start off with
I had the first session of my meditation
course which was really good I really
really enjoyed that there were about 20
maybe 25 people who were doing it mostly
graduate students who were looking to
either overcome anxiety or depression or
he just more like me he wanted to kind
of optimize what they do in university
and it was a really constructive session
and we've been given homework and in
doing everyday but then immediately
after that I had the physics society
social when I arrived and was within
five seconds put behind the bar mix and
cocktails which I've never done before
and especially well actually I suppose
it was good that none of the cocktails
were proper cocktails because our
social rep had invented lots of
physics-based cocktails which were
called like the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle with the Cherenkov radiation
the dark matter and stuff like that so
you're pretty much free to mate them off
the UN and then immediately after that
we went out because it was a friend of
mine who graduated in he matriculated
that is to say he started University of
my year but because I'm doing the four
year course and basically do three of
course most of my friends are graduating
but he came back for his birthday and
then we went out for that and I had to
take him back home in a taxi fairly soon
after we went out though he had a better
night than one of my friends who put his
facebook status the next morning burn
mine he'd been in Oxford that night went
to a club and then his next morning his
status was I just got woken up by a nun
in Heathrow Airport how am I here
so yeah had a better night than him but
then I started going to lectures so in
my masters here when you have six
lectures a week which is about heart of
what we had previously
but the way I see it is they're more
like graduate lectures than
undergraduate lectures so it's not what
you're giving given all the information
that you need for the course in it you
kind of treat it as an introduction to
the course and then you go away and you
do your reading you make a notes based
on that and then you answer the tutorial
sheet based on that which is an
interesting way of doing things it's
different from before and I think I
prefer it this way and we have your like
we haven't had any tutorials yet so we
again have similarly fewer tutorials
although similarly I think they're more
of a graduate bent rather than just
being spoon-fed information not the us
being fed information previously but
also so I've been spending a lot of time
in libraries in particular the Radcliffe
science library which is the main
science library so I should point out in
Oxford you have your departmental
library which for me is the RSL or if
you're doing English the English faculty
library or but you know the history of
calabria whether you've also got Central
Library which is the Adlon
and all the other subject libraries like
satellites to the bottom and the
building itself is subject
I said I think it is a subject libraries
it's a legal deposit library which means
it contains a copy of every book that's
been published in UK so there's
something ridiculous like 10 million
books and modeling but then in addition
to those you also have your college
library so I can work in any of these I
could go like if I wants to work in the
Anthropology library and I do actually
but there's the Araki of Science Library
which is like a 19th century building
which has an underground bit which is
where I tend to work and it's like a
labyrinth of books I really like it you
can kind of get lost in bookshelves but
there's also the college library which
is are omitting a lot of work I actually
made a whole video about my college
library on the college channel but it's
an late 18th century building and it's
got a more relaxed atmosphere because
it's a codified room because some Peters
is a laid back kind of college but
working there quite a lot not as much as
normal yet it's still ramping up in
intensity term has started going about
how I thought it would we haven't hit
full output yet start going to the gym
properly I went to the gym that whole
load over the summer because I didn't
have that much else better to do and
I've kind of got the gym bug so started
going again properly unfortunately I've
started going again along with what
looks like a slew of Olympians because
there's a bunch of people know who are
Duda Chris just like incredibly big so I
feel quite inadequate one thing that
happened this week which I think
highlights two things about Oxford which
I think it's important thing to talk
about is the yesterday on Saturday I got
a lot time I write so the way that it
works in Oxford at least it's and Peters
is that you have your fob so the
electronic thing and that lets you into
things like the library and the college
late at night and your accommodation
block so that letting you but like II
which just lets me into my room didn't
the locker jammed and so I'll say Vicky
got great I don't need this
I'd say I won't have to go out to the
college and talk to the porters the
porters are there's all there's a
porters Lodge in every college and you
always have at least one porter on duty
the idea is if you have a problem like
in my case
my door won't open or I need to send a
message to a tutor or there's been an
emergency or you know anything you go to
the porters and they'll directly to the
right people know they're kind of like
the watches of the college and that
they're fantastic of what we do and to
be honest it actually makes quite a
difference what kind of party you have
in your college and we have just such
good courtesans and theatres like there
that's perfectly its people so they were
like fine we'll give you a spare key
let's see what happens but it's Becky in
doesn't work right right so I'm back up
to college now so I was really quite
stressed but what happened was when I
went back into college I could hear
music which isn't that uncommon in some
pieces because we have a really big
Chapel in the middle of college you get
loads of people rehearsing and doing
performances and stuff like that it
wasn't that unusual but I recognized the
music so I went up to the door and the
chaplain there's a little sort of [ __ ]
in the middle of it which you can look
through and they were playing
Appalachian Spring by Aaron Copland
which is one of my favorite pieces of
music and I've never actually heard it
live before so I sort of stuck my head
on the door and sat down and mice to
listen to this piece of music completely
free and completely randomly didn't know
it was happening
was informed it was a guy who needed a
video of him conducting something for an
application for a fund so you got a
bunch of musicians together like let's
just do Appalachian Spring so it was
just completely by random look because
my key didn't work I managed to have the
opportunity to listen to the music and
you just those kind of opportunities
just don't really happen like that many
places like you just get the chapel
being used by these groups or you'll
stumble across some Society that you've
never heard of having a socialized
really cool that kind of thing happens
all the time
there anyway the conclusion is I went to
the lodge I know that okay that's not a
problem and within half an hour they've
got a guy to come in knock my lock
through and put a new one in gave me a
new key so it wasn't even a big deal for
them and Porter's are amazing like some
PETA supporters are the biggest large
feline fur fine so you know I think
that's it for this week actually and
there hasn't been too much work so far
just because it's week one and things
take a little bit of time to get going
but next week I have a few things like
that same base of lectures don't hum go
tutorial next week we're getting more
into the problem sheets next week though
I did do one this week which is already
handed in and I think there's a few
social things going on and we have our
next physics society lecture which is on
relativistic quantum information I think
that's it though it's not too much going
on next week somebody made a request
actually to do a video sort of like life
in a day which I will do at some point
but I'm just waiting for term to get
back - no not that there's really ever a
normal day but they basically when
there's an actually representative
matter work so the moment I'm not doing
as much work as you would do in the
middle of term just because it's still
ramping up so I will do that at some
point so yeah thanks for watching I'll
see you next week